so you really have to see this uh donald
trump jr is so desperate for time on air
but also desperate for opportunities to
talk about how his
beloved father the former president is
just so liked by everyone
that he went on sean hannity's fox news
program last night on which there were
multiple segments about a group of
people that came out in florida with
trump flags to cheer donald trump on
president's day as donald trump drove i
guess from golfing back to his resort or
something like that and this as i was
watching this
i actually almost felt slightly sorry
for don jr who of course is just
so desperate to be liked by his dad
but so desperate to try to keep the
party going for lack of a better term
check this out first you're going to see
a clip here of sean hannity claiming
that this group of several
it appears to be several hundred trump
supporters spontaneously appeared to
cheer on trump as he returned from
golfing now if you watch the video
you're gonna notice people with gigantic
flags like eight foot ten foot flags
these are not things you can say oh
trump's going to drive through i'll just
pop into 7-eleven and get a 10-foot
don't tread on me or magga or maga or
trump flag you have to plan for this
stuff the police cordons clearly were
organized ahead of time anyway nothing
about it seems spontaneous but here's
hannity saying look at this spontaneous
thing that just popped up very day
take a look right there see that video
see what's on your screen a few hours
ago spontaneously
thousands of people
in palm beach lined up in support of the
former president as his motorcade
traveled through florida
i have a question mitch mcconnell john
thune how come you never had this kind
of enthusiasm at any of your events take
a look a defiant sean hannity there
saying hey listen
a senator like john thune
barely known to anybody
never had people with
flags
cheering them like a former president of
the united states what a kind of strange
flex that is but anyway then that's not
all because in comes don jr to talk
about the quote totally organic parade
of flag bearing trumpists that appeared
uh take a look at this
you're looking at dad coming back from
golf did you see
thousands of people out of nowhere
nobody nobody organized it that i could
see necessarily nobody associated with
your father that i know of do you
uh no i mean this is totally organic and
again it just shows that the american
people are with donald trump uh those
millions of people sean i saw it all day
i put up a separate video even to the
one that you posted earlier now that's
it's actually really funny how hannity
hedges
nobody organized thousands of people and
a police presence well no one associated
with your father anyway and i guess what
sean hannity means is that trump didn't
organize it himself okay and don jr
really seems to be struggling with the
math there and you can't you kept
hearing this during the impeachment
trial actually the disenfranchisement
of 74 million people who voted for trump
a few hundred or even a thousand people
getting out to support someone in a
country of 330 million people when joe
biden got millions more votes than
donald trump
what mathematical significance do a few
hundred or even a thousand people have
now on the facts they're of course lying
to you
there was nothing organic or spontaneous
about this event it was president's day
yesterday people came from relatively
far away from the for this they drove
with their flags
and people knew about the event starting
at least a week before it was being
promoted there was nothing coincidental
about it here's one advertisement for
the event from right side broadcasting
network starting to promote this well in
advance they even say bring your flags
those flags you can't just stop in a 711
or a walmart and get an 8-foot trump
flag you've got to plan ahead and what's
more sad i mean listen there's there's a
lot of sad stuff going on here
one thing is like they always have to go
further they could just go with there
was great turnout on president's day for
donald trump okay all right well a few
hundred supporters came out that's great
why do you have to say it was
spontaneous and it just popped up out of
nowhere like it's completely
unbelievable obviously it didn't pop out
of nowhere
but maybe what's more sad
is that donald trump jr is desperate not
just for relevance
but he's so desperate for dad's approval
and that is it you know we this is a
cycle that repeats itself we don't have
to get all psychological but donald
trump was desperate for his dad's
approval and his dad treated him
terribly and that's where a lot of
trump's complex comes from and it seems
to be repeated exactly between donald
trump and donald trump jr it's all sad
quite frankly
but it is what it is as they say and
hopefully this will at some point kind
of wind down